dans son appartement de chisinau cette
jeune femme héberge une famille
ukrainienne
depuis le début de la guerre déjà 230
mille réfugiés venus d'ukraine ont
transité par la moldavie
nous n'attendons rien en retour nous
avions juste la possibilité de le faire
et nous nous sommes dit que nous avions
beaucoup de chance de ne pas avoir
nous-mêmes à fuir la guerre
pourtant les moldaves craignent d'être
la prochaine cible de moscou cette
ancienne république soviétique d'à peine
2 millions 600 mille habitants est l'un
des pays les plus pauvres d'europe une
partie de son territoire la transnistrie
et déjà aux mains des séparatistes pro
russes depuis 1991 une zone qui se
trouve à seulement une cinquantaine de
kilomètres de la ville ukrainienne
d'odessa
les troupes russes se trouvent déjà
stationnés illégalement dans notre pays
depuis des décennies et cela nous rend
vulnérable
nous nous sentons pas en sécurité
surtout maintenant que nous voyons la
guerre en ukraine
la moldavie craint d'être dépassé par la
situation
elle demande le soutien des occidentaux
pour gérer le flux de réfugiés mais
aussi pour se protéger de son voisin
russe ces derniers jours les visites
officielles se sont ainsi succédé à
szczecin à josep borrell le chef de la
diplomatie européenne
jean yves le drian le ministre français
des affaires étrangères mais aussi
anthony blinken le secrétaire d'état
américain
nous allons faire le maximum pour
resserrer les liens entre nos deux pays
dans le domaine de l'économie de
l'éducation
nous allons rapprocher nos peuples car
nous voulons que notre amitié avec la
moldavie grandissent et deviennent plus
forts dès le début de l'invasion russe
en ukraine la moldavie a fermé son
espace aérien et a déclaré l'état
d'urgence pour une durée de deux mois
jeudi dernier la présidente moldave a
officiellement demandé l'adhésion de la
moldavie à l'union européenne dans
l'espoir de se protéger d'une possible
attaque de moscou